مياده بعد دخول شاحنات المساعدات كيف تبدو
الاوضاع الانسانيه في قطاع غزه الاوضاع
الانسانيه للاسف في قطاع غزه لازالت سيئه
جدا وتوصف بالكارثي من عده منظمات دوليه
الصحه العالميه الاونر وبرنامج الاغذيه
حتى الامم المتحده ما دخل من مساعدات حتى
الان وفق التقديرات الرسميه لا يتناسب مع
حجم الكارثه في في قطاع غزه هناك مشكله
كبيره ترتبط بتوفر الوقود الذي يشغل
المستشفيات حتى تشتغل معظم الاجهزه التي
يمكن ان تساعد في انقاذ الارواح هناك
مساعدات طبيه من انواع مختلفه تتعلق ايضا
بالعمليات الجراحيه الطارئه ايضا فيما
يتعلق بتوفير الاجهزه التي ترتبط مثلا
بمرضى الفشل الكلوي هذا كله عدا المساعدات
الانسانيه الاخرى تتعلق بالغذاء والدواء
السكن و كل هذه التفاصيل الاخرى التي هي
بالفعل في اقل وادنى مستوياتها في قطاع
غزه وتتدهور كل يوم بشكل اكبر